welcome to get cooking in cloud where we
share the best recipes to apply in your
cloud kitchen I'm Priyanka and in this
episode I am pleased to welcome back
Jade person to talk about another mobile
app back in service solution
[Music]
hello John welcome to get with the
implant
thanks franca I'm super excited to share
today's solution I think it's a real
winner well so far you've shown us some
really great recipes we've looked at
some architectures using firebase and
then another one using firebase and App
Engine standard and then yet another one
using firebase and App Engine flexible
environment so we are all wondering what
are we cooking up today well the
ingredients for today's recipe are the
App Engine standard environment and the
endpoints frameworks ah yes I know that
endpoints framework for the App Engine
standard environment generates api's
client libraries and discovery
documentation for an app engine app
exactly this means you don't have to
write wrappers to handle communication
with App Engine and with the client
library is generated by endpoints you
can make direct API calls from your
mobile app using endpoints with App
Engine gives you an app platform that
monitors updates and scales for hosting
environments what sort of apps might not
be a great fit for this well I don't
recommend this architecture if your app
requires automatic real-time data
synchronization across devices for those
apps you'll want to see one of the
solutions that includes firebase so in
Priyanka's kitchen could you help me
understand this with an example well
remember when we talked about updating
player scores and rankings since all
client devices needed the updated scores
one of our previous solutions using
firebase is better for that use case so
what are some of the other apps that are
not a great fit so if your back-end
services require custom servers or
third-party libraries you'll want to
look at it the solution with firebase
and App Engine flexible environments ah
like for example if I needed custom
payment processing server to process
payments and Priyanka's kitchen ah've
then that payment processing server can
be on App Engine flexible environment
integrating with firebase right exactly
and finally if your systems don't
support SSL you'll want to choose
another solution because SSL is required
by endpoints and if App Engine what
endpoints sounds like a good solution
for developers
then how can they find out more link
below is a set of
getting started tutorials that show how
to build the hello endpoint sample app
this sample lets you send simple
messages the backend service is
implemented on App Engine and exposed to
the mobile app with endpoints awesome
well if your use case requires making
direct API calls from the mobile app
that it's worth checking out Cloud
endpoints and try this recipe that's all
for today on get cooking in cloud gem
thank you so much for being here
absolutely it was fun and if you'd like
to know more about today's recipe you
can check out the endpoints with App
Engine guides and reference Docs join us
next time to see what we're cooking up
if you like this video then check out
the other episodes in the series and
don't forget to subscribe to our channel
so you can be notified about new
episodes of get cooking and cloud as
well as other great google cloud cutter
you